moses hawking welcome
hi good to be here thanks so much for
coming on the program
absolutely thanks for the invitation i'm
really excited for this
moses art is incredible
he identifies as water he's been
taking incredible unbelievable
photos of water and has a background in
architecture as well
and spiritually
very aligned really excited to
play with oceanic feeling and
also get the chance to
showcase some of this
in its nuances
and also its relation to our metaphysics
which is really interesting
so let's let's start off by
playing spiritually with
the metaphysics of infinity expressing
itself
do you feel like that's what this is
yeah
i mean there's there's something that is
beyond and that something is like the
absolute nothing and when it doesn't
feel like being nothing
in one second big bang life sparks and
here we are you know so yeah absolutely
oh that's great so
you really resonate with
lila are you familiar with the sanskrit
term lila the cosmic player the divine
play
i mean i think there's so many mysticism
mythologies and religions
and i keep my mind blank i don't retain
names number like i'm not a history buff
you know what i mean i i have no idea
so if so conceptually yes but name now
yeah yeah interesting so conceptually is
the absolute
undergoing a playful
modulatory experience
[Music]
of all of these forms
right yeah that thing that is before
language before knowing before
the before but it's before before
because we can't even talk about it
because it's so far back
yeah from the human experience which is
kind of the opposite of
that we're so invested in
being and that thing is the absolute
yeah i've have one video about that
about what exists outside of time and
space
and just no space
like yeah we keep thinking about it like
oh because we're thinking about like
we need to travel far out into space to
find what exists outside of it
but that's not gonna work because the
further you go the further it's gonna
expand
but if you kind of go inside
you might find that nothingness for a
glimpse of a second
before you get back into the being
yeah yeah yeah
take the inward journey
all the way to your source
all the way to nothingness shunya the
void
and once you see that
this is a bunch of emptiness that's
dancing
right yeah but this is good
yeah yeah and once you go out from that
point
like lao tza and so many others in these
mystic traditions said
it's very much like wu way it's like
this effortless
action that comes upon the
god realized state or that infinite
realized state
because
you recognize that these are expressions
of the same source of the same
infinitude
so there's never a tendency to do any
harm right because it would just be on
to yourself
yeah yeah i mean i'm talking to myself
right now
exactly it's an internal conversation
within that space but yeah i mean it's
it's so layered
the between function like what is the
function we're
here for and then
also when you detach from the human
story then you also
don't see the harm or the suffering you
know i mean like yeah
so it's a very tricky line to work
i'm really happy you brought this up
i've been playing around a lot with
simultaneity and so simultaneously
we hold this very non-dual
realization about the nothingness
dancing
and yet also we hold the simultaneously
the dualistic concession
which is that there is suffering and
there's well-being
and we want to architect towards
well-being and prosperity
right yeah but you just have to always
always remember um like we make
games right so we make
rules we build the space for the game
whether it's an actual court
or software hardware and then we're the
one that ends up
playing inside of the game too yeah
right so it's
but for humans most of the quest is
um to keep playing the game until you
realize that there
that you made it you made the game that
you're inside of exactly so
but the game is only good if you don't
realize that
why not why can't it also be good if you
realize it
well then then then we shift to a
different game right
which is what what's the different game
upon infinite realization what's the
game that you've shifted to
i think it's the shift is the shift of
what motivates you
like what's the motivator right that's
what i'm saying it's a different game
because what's what's the shift for you
in what's the motivation shift now
for me this for me it's always been the
same the motivation was from inside
like i see myself that i belong to life
life is mine building that's why the
architecture
building houses is nature building
houses for
consciousness right so building and
making
um the nature is in the business of
construction
you know that's what nature does yeah
trees are buildings
so i'm so i'm there with you
about let's not destroy architecture
yeah
and architecture is people plants animal
yes
that's architecture so destruction is
not ideal it's not a good thing because
we actually put so much energy
to construction yeah so whenever we
destroy that's just the pure waste
right but then i get to a place where
i'm like but there is no waste
so that's what i mean so it depends on
which layer you're
in your discussion exactly right so if i
talk to another person
in the human story i'm like let's not
destroy
yep because we put a lot of energy in
building and that includes even
your child when you have a child you put
a lot of energy into building that
right there's nothing worse than
somebody destroying your child
right you put so much energy into
building that right
so so that's why i think i try to stay
within
when i talk about those things within
the human story for humans
yeah because outside of that that
conversation might be destructive for
humans
because they're like oh well it doesn't
matter yeah
right this is this is why simultaneity
is really important
across all these layers because in many
ways
people come to the this final
realization of emptiness dancing
of non-duality and
it's really important to also be able to
hold at the same time
like a jedi you can navigate all these
layers because then you can
be in the dream world
and also when you have a conversation
with somebody recognize that there is
that feeling of a billion people still
not having access to clean water
or into sustainable sources of food for
themselves and whatnot or maybe
their consciousness does not yet have
the house
that you're saying that architecture
nature is like providing these
houses for consciousness which is super
interesting way of viewing it as well
and so that's
part of the critical realization has
been
navigating across all of these layers
simultaneously
and that even upon the ultimate
realization
yeah there's still never a
tendency to destroy because
there's no
feeling worse than destruction
after so much billions of years of
play that then created the creation for
us to look
at ourselves through this
yeah so the best thing we can do is try
and even maximize as much
more portals in for people to come
through as
infants yeah yeah and i think i mean
it's just we're seeing um because you
have to look at life
if if you want to see the movement
within life you have to look at life as
something that
is um perfect as it is
so at that moment you can look at things
and
be like okay i understand why this is
here and why this is happening
it's not ideal it hurts but
the goal and where it's going is to a
specific place
right so like i like to say i don't
believe like in
evolution or creation i believe in the
evolution of creation
yes right so we are constantly making
and evolving in the making so we're
making better
all the time right human beings you know
100 years ago
50 would die from a simple infection or
at birth or whatever
life expectancy was so low and suddenly
you know boom where we get to a place we
improve
there's less pains there's less
suffering there's less disease there's
less
so it's not like we started in paradise
totally as far as
the physical world these vehicles um so
it's it's always good to just look at
i don't know cars from the first
wheel of the log of wood that rolled
down the mountain
to a self-driving car yep right so when
we look at evolution
of vehicles because this is what we're
in we're inside of a vehicle
so you look at evolution of vehicles you
start to see how we're constantly
improving
moving forward to a place where this
vehicle
will be even better but also at what
point my self-driving car will think
wait this is what i am i'm a
self-driving car
what's a person
like i don't yeah i don't even know what
that is
i'm here and i'm driving from here to
there
a person that doesn't exist right so for
a
self-driving car in the future a person
will be like that invisible soul
that not only made it but it's actually
using it yes right so it's like
so for a lot of people they're in that
self-driving car
they just see themselves as the
self-driving car
there's nothing that actually evolved
that vehicle to the place that it is
for a specific function function yeah
yeah
ooh that's that's the critical part of
it it's almost like
one of the biggest gifts that you can
render humanity as ramana maharshi said
is to realize yourself as
infinity as god expressing itself and
yet
also when you go all the way
to that infiniti to that source
what happens is that you recognize that
similarly and we may we may touch on
this
throughout our conversation do you have
you part
have you partaked in entheogens
psychedelics entheogen
means unleashing the divine within
unleashing god within
right and
like when you participate
for example with 5mu dmt
within moments you're
recognizing that we'll get to this this
oceanic
feeling which we're already in
and talking about
but that you recognize the trajectory of
what it took for you to be able to
be this expression of
source experiencing itself
that's what happens when you rock it
into your
entheogenic experience you're like wow
this is so
divine and profound
and to really just be
child like awe and happiness
because you are this expression this
secretion of that infinitude
experiencing itself right
and there's i mean there's something
that because i've been thinking about
that
part a lot and in because
again the meaning of life is living it's
life itself
in this game right in this specific
layer of human beings
and then i found that
um for many people that are not born
into
an ideal setting where you have
those feelings just from life itself
right
so if i couldn't find that happiness and
joy and that meaning within
um my environment family connections
hobby life you know like because that's
usually most people on the good
end of things are distracted in a
beautiful way
with life itself they find happiness
they find joy they find connection they
find
through that through you know having
great parents great environment good
education
good relationships they're fulfilled
they're motivated right
and then there's people which i would
include myself in that
you don't have that when you grow up so
there's other places for you to find
that
and then we go maybe out to nature
maybe connect to things that are not on
the human story or human level
we connect the things that come through
those for example
substances could be meditation could be
could be a lot of different ways right
so there is basically
a place for everyone to find that and
it's and i found that maybe
i'm in the minority too of the people
that had to go
outside of the human story to find peace
love harmony
joy connection motivation right that
yeah i've two things to say there
that it'll be interesting to hear your
perspective about
typically what is called maya
in the sanskrit tradition especially adi
shankara
theory developing this out is that the
and in many ways it's kind of like
lakshmi this sort of
goddess of temptation and intoxication
the world the dreamed creation
is in many ways the place
where if you seek happiness
and peace to extract it
from the dream from maya from the planet
you will always fail whereas
this is very much like what rupert spira
says
whereas when you go all the way inward
you're you recognize that your source is
sat [ __ ] ananda
its existence consciousness bliss
and that then you bring
peace and happiness to the world
to everything you do i guess let's start
there how do you feel about that first
right like it puts things in perspective
for those that don't have it
right so if you're stressed anxious life
is hard
then you can always stop and go back to
wait what am i
i'm just pure consciousness
where am i i'm not this right now i'm in
a very peaceful place
and then like you said you bring that so
you can manage to calm yourself
but we're talking already to a place
where you can have that conversation
most people can't even go there
the anxiety is crippling interesting the
stress is crippling
their body is crippling right so okay so
you're talking about when you're still
in the space of
seeking peace and happiness externally
that at that point then
there's some sort of
like in the parable of the prodigal son
in the abrahamic tradition there's this
turn
inward that happens right
and so would that be then sort of an
important
one of your also important framings of
what's happening is to turn rather than
seeking the peace and happiness
in a relationship or in a substance or
in an experience
to instead recognize yeah yeah because
because it's not out there
you can't find anything outside of you i
mean nobody can make you feel better
and that thing no thing can make you
feel better that's definitely
um and i think what i'm talking about is
the
so in this layer
we're here to build that's where we have
these vehicles
we're here to build architecture yes
we're building
house for consciousness and in that
equation water is consciousness you're
already the house this is the first
house the secondary house and it keeps
growing right
so now the only question is what
will be um what will it take for you to
continue building and making
right so that's why i said that
the idea of even suffering harm all
those things
don't matter really to water
it's just a matter of your vehicle in as
a person right
so it's like cars have accidents but
when they self-driving cars
there will be no accidents right so it
doesn't mean that the world was
bad because cars used to have accidents
it just again the evolution of creation
it's the time it takes to evolve create
make
to a certain point so i think as
humans in this layer
[Music]
life will do whatever it takes to make
sure you're alive
you're building you're making you're
creating you have a house you have
the technology you have you know you
keep moving life
forward and you don't have a choice
either
you can't stop drinking eating you know
what i mean like
you do not have that free will totally
totally this vehicle as long as you're
in this vehicle
totally this is how it works yeah this
is the game you're in you signed in for
it
but you know you'll find out later that
you did yeah yeah you're not going to
find that out
while you're in it kind of thing but
nice
okay so let's see if i hit the ball back
here one of the core things to recognize
is that
as we talk about like in this example at
the parable of the prodigal son
when you're seeking happiness
in the sense of a material
possession externally
you're going to run into misery but
when you're seeking the basic need to be
met of clean air or water or food or
shelter or electricity etc
that that is really important because
you can't
get air in a sense from
the inward you you have to get clean
air from finding clean air to sustain
your next steps both inward and outward
and so
meeting basic needs is something really
important
in that outward expression and that's
why
you've used the word architecture i
really like that i
i talk about infinite creation a lot
that this is
all in infinite creative expressions
is what this all eternally is doing and
yet
i like your use of architecting because
we have not only architected these
vehicles but we've also architected
the houses
as well that we live in we architected
the air
water food electricity those basic needs
and so the constant process of
architecting
to maximize the basic needs being met so
more people can go
all the way in and all the way out
by the way i typically use all the way
in
meaning the infinity or source
realization
and then all the way out is kind of like
the entrepreneurship or the art or the
creativity
or the engineering or the science it's
like express it's like the firework
outward yeah yeah yeah
you you that resonates yeah absolutely
okay yeah
and then the next i guess the next place
i'd like to go
and we'll get to one of the things you
were mentioning earlier
is that
the sufi traditions
they say that they have this phrase it's
it's the unity of all finding
because you gave this really interesting
while you were talking a bit ago
that each of us has our own flavor or
our own style
or taste if you will of communion
with this oceanic-ness and so
that's what ibna rabbi and
william chitik and so many others
are now expressing with
what al wujud is that each one of these
expressions of source or infinity
has its own unique style of both
communing
inwards so some people and ask you this
some people
we mentioned earlier you can sit for
these 10-day silent meditation retreats
you can
read mystic books
around the union with the absolute you
can take entheogens
there are so many different paths and so
that means there are so many different
ways to
unite yoga union with the absolute
and then there's all these different
ways to express yourself outward as well
so how does that concept of
your unique style of finding and also
i'd like to ask you about your unique
style of finding
how you came to the realization
right but first we have to say
is that the purpose
like is that what we're here for
like hide and seek because when you're
outside of this body
you know it all right i mean it's only a
temporary
moment in your life that you don't yeah
while you're in this body you're limited
right it's like the horse we put the
blinds on yeah to make sure they can do
their task
because if you see everything yeah it's
overwhelming right
if you believe i am the body because
even that's why we don't see water
that's why we don't see all of the
spirit that's around us
yeah because if you saw that you
wouldn't be able to do the function of
building this house right you'd be in an
ocean of oxygen and nitrogen
and so yeah yeah so
so i think it's important to recognize
that we
know everything there's nothing really
hidden
it's only when we are right now we're
like astronauts right we took a drop of
water from the ocean
we packaged it in this body so now
you're away from home
which is the source of all your
suffering in pain
because you're disconnected from who you
really are the bigger ocean
everyone you know and love and that's
why as humans we try to seek that
connection again
with other humans well it's like when
you see this drop of water
kind of like touching and suddenly like
right
but we can't do that because we're still
have that skin between us
right but we can't see like magnets of
consciousness
trying to you know get back to that
place
you know so we're like physically we
just get there it's that feeling you
have when you hold somebody
and you can't hold them close enough
like you try to hug them so much that
you want to dissolve into each other but
you can't
so we are in a temporary place
we are basically astronauts away from
home
right now as human beings so if for some
people
it helps them knowing and understanding
that that's what's going on that's why
you feel this way but it's also
temporary
but there are people that are able to
function within that equation and
do their purpose so it's it's a
again it's a tricky one because
in the human story all that exists
but your human story is short and once
you're outside of it you're back to that
infinite
to that oceanic feeling you dissolve
back to that ocean
of consciousness and you're back there
and you're like oh
i get it now i know where i came from i
know where i've been i know all my past
life
and i see the future one that i'm gonna
jump into once again
by choice and i know that i'm i'm not
gonna know again
and i'm gonna forget and i'm gonna you
know and we're brave to do that but we
do
and so it's it's uh so i'm trying to say
is that
i don't think the meaning of life is to
discover the meaning of life i think the
meaning of life is to live life
and then there are people that for them
to live life which i was one of them
was not acceptable until i knew
everything
right so so in a way i'm kind of like
the the brat
you know i'm like okay no i'm not
playing this game
i'm telling you i don't know everything
about this game yeah
until i expose every corner right
but then but then it's a dangerous game
to play because some people unravel the
game and then
they lose motivation they lose meaning
or they lose purpose right
so that's that's where my mind is how do
we do that
responsibly exactly right like how do we
so that's why i wouldn't push somebody
to
do any type of substance or any type of
practice that might not be
it's very subjective right like i cannot
my journey is my journey and like you
said our personalities are so different
um not because of the source but because
of the where we are now
right this vehicle is different than
your vehicle yeah
my experience is site-specific so
and that's what shapes our different
personalities but outside of the body
when we go back
there's only one personality there's
only one yeah
um so my personal experience will never
be a good way for somebody else to find
their way
yeah it's up to them yeah but the only
thing i can say is that i know
i found it in me yeah nobody else's
guiding teaching i found it so once you
are able to
shut down the thoughts the stress
the other people's voices that live in
your head once you shut all that down
and you really listen to who you are
which is more like hearing the gut
it's beyond language it's beyond like
once that surfaces up
you got it you feel it yeah and suddenly
you know wow this is who i am this is my
purpose this is what i'm here for yes
yes
um yeah yeah there's so many ways to
take that bit i love it
one of the things that's been coming up
a good amount is that
very similarly to how
there are so many top-level
athletes around the world there are also
top-level people that have went all the
way
inward to recognize their true nature
right and and so there's not
a big amount of people that are saying
go and train multiple hours per day to
become a peak athlete
in the discipline and so very similarly
there's nobody
saying oh you should train multiple
hours per day to recognize your own true
infinitude expressing itself and so for
those that
are interested in recognizing their
nature
it all although there are all these
different paths all these different
styles and tastes
the end is one yeah and
that then upon that realization
what happens is the reason why there's
so many people that say that it's the
most
important thing you can do is because
then
you no longer carry around
and we're going to be interviewing frank
yang here on the show
soon who's also in the state of infinity
realization
where there's this he uses this analogy
this condom
in a sense it's like you put a big
tide a condom around your neck and now
you're in this bubble of ego separation
and you don't even recognize you're the
fish in the ocean right
and so then when you're in that space
what's happening is that you're trying
to
get happiness and peace from
the world from relationships and
substances and all these other things
and you have this fear and there's fear
which lao tzu said is the greatest
illusion
you are already source you are already
infinity there's
nothing to fear and so another really
good
analogy for this is that the double
helical structure
dna in biology because you have this
discovery since 1953 that
we used to just say that we are brothers
and sisters and there was like this big
you know movement around the planet we
are there
and then in 1953 we're like oh [ __ ]
we're
99.9 percent genetically
similar to each other and we're 0.1
percent different
as humans and that's another way to
explain
the unity and diversity at the same time
because we take on these different form
ocean this channel for water
that we are it takes on the different
form that's why this is atlas and that's
moses and that
your israeli i'm armenian and that you
know you do this incredible art and i do
these
shows and other content so we kind of
are our unique
expressions as well so there's like a
unique outward
and a unique style of finding inward and
so
that's sort of been one of the ways of
even on the level of
form on a level of
physicalism and dna and biology
you can come to these same realizations
because it is one it's truth like it
manifests itself
physically and metaphysically because
obviously if
because we understand that it comes from
the metaphysics into the physics
but for most people it's like you know
physics first now
oh it happened to be also the same over
there like it's actually
it's actually that way around but that's
fine but
um but i think i mean what you describe
is basically
fractals right like understanding the
fractal
nature of consciousness understanding
this
that spiral of life i think that was one
of the first things for me when i
understood
what a fractal is but truly what it is
in being that thing both
in this scale or in the bigger scale or
i mean when you truly understand the
independence
of the fractal in its scale it actually
helps you also understand
how all like a single cell is as
conscious as you are
because consciousness is a fractal it's
independent of scale
and people think well a fly it's small
it doesn't have a big brain
it's not as intelligent or conscious as
i am
i'm like well you don't understand
consciousness consciousness
like a drop of water is as intelligent
as you are
or take a whale it's like the size of a
building
and is it as intelligent as you are it
can be bigger could be smaller but
so that fractal is really the nature of
consciousness
and then when you look what i've learned
from faces of water and from looking at
the images of water
is that in consciousness there's
infinite amount of
movement and life is
movement that's what life is and then
movement becomes
musical movement political movement
social movements but
as life as basically that thing that is
nothing
is coming into some kind of um
if you want to go from point a to point
b you have to have a reason
so you have to have you have to be a
conscious being to decide well i want to
go
there so then starts a movement right
so there's intention movement
and that movement now has a form because
there's something that's not moving
there's something that is moving right
so now we have a form and that form is
shaped
by the intention right so you can
imagine
a shark a dolphin two completely
different intentions
coming into life into movement into form
and and anything's form informs you
of the intention right that's why i can
walk around the world and i know
the intention behind everything
according to their form
it's very easy so in
in the global consciousness in that
ocean of consciousness
there's infinite movement and each
movement is a character
and each character has intention and has
a form and so on and so on so
and then you show up i show up and
elephant show ups and tree shop
you know things coming to life
so it's it's but in in the ocean itself
there's no limit
you know there's this infinity and ease
of free
it's free form everything can exist
everything can show up it's
three-dimensional it's four-dimensional
it's 11-dimensional
you know things can become anything and
everything
but here in the material world we
consciousness came into existence with
this
building blocks right we have matter
and that's where it's different now we
have matter you have building blocks
those building blocks have shape they
have rules
and then you have water which is the
agent of consciousness within
this world of building blocks and now
water is playing with those building
blocks and seeing what can i make
what can i do right yes but you're bound
by matter
you're bound by those building blocks
and that's what's so different from the
pure consciousness
which is boundless free form
into living in this material world
suddenly there's form
there's limitation there's physics
laws of physics science all those things
now come into play
yeah but their con consciousness is
playing with itself
that's science where most people try to
take
science to investigate consciousness
but science is science of matter yeah
yeah it's not the science of
consciousness the art
philosophy you know the the
expression through poetry visual art all
those things that's the science of
consciousness
so i think that's maybe one of the
things that you're trying to talk about
how do we bring people
back to consciousness and and today the
biggest problem is that most people
learned in school
that life is random and meaningless
the theory of evolution it's random and
meaningless
and i think that's that's where we both
agree on like we have to shake people
out of that
back to the idea of like it's not random
and it's not meaningless
you know the map of evolution is true
but it's the map of the create
you know the creative force within
evolution yeah that's why everything
makes sense at each step
yes
moses i've been playing around with this
quite a bit that
we mentioned a little bit ago that
there's not this
tendency in culture to
ship people off to to go and practice
for several hours a day of learning how
to play the violin
or learning how to you know hit tennis
balls or whatever sport or activity it
is
but we also recognize that it might be
the most upstream all the way
up at the source so typically we do
things
downstream like when
like the healthcare systems like
downstream you wait until something
happens then you go in
it's not prevented if you don't go all
the way upstream to the exact
cellular intracellular deficiency
that's then causing the downstream
bigger pathology in a
bunch of tissue that you then go to the
hospital to do so
very similarly and you were talking
about fractals fractals this
is what we're describing here is that
the more you go
upstream to the source
that the more that you recognize that
then
downstream all of the healing
all of the morality all of the ethics
all of the things that we
frequently wonder how do we figure out
how to do this
they get solved naturally because you
recognize
the nature of what is actually happening
and so that
reason why it's becoming so much more
important for people to
even recognize why are we saying this
why are we having a show about
spirituality and metaphysics and oceanic
feeling why do we care about talking
about this
rather than talking about the weather
and talking about sports and talking
about
all of these other transient surface
level things is because
we're talking about what is not
transient we're talking about what
is permanent we're talking about the
absolute the ultimate
that then expresses itself as the
transient as
all of this finite creation
and in doing so when you come to that
realization
it's just the effortless morality and
ethics
and prosperity that becomes so
much easier to
harmonize on and
that's why as i was writing
some notes while you were talking one of
them was that
even at the level of the fractal even at
the level of
mathematical self-similarity
and recursion and chaos
and recognizing that
fundamentally
the different expressions of form that
we
take on as fireworks
of infinity makes it so that
i see you as the same source
expressing itself as a different
beautiful
form you have your own unique firework
and that's why the west is not wrong
about individuation
the east is so spot on about non-duality
and oneness unity and yet
the west is very right about infinity
expressing itself as these unique
fireworks individuation
and so to merge those two together has
been something that's
really pivotal and fundamental
spirituality and science the collective
and the individual right and i think we
just
right now i see the future of life not
on this planet
and i think those things will happen
when we leave this place
so for example let's say tomorrow you
have a new
because that's a new creature in space
when you have a new let's say some kind
of a space
station right and you have people living
in that space station
now there's a bigger body and human
beings are the sales
of that body right everything we know
about life here socially
is gone you're not owning land anymore
you're not
having your own job and making like all
those ideas that come from
what you know because right now we have
this like capitalist
communist right individual collective
but suddenly when you're in that space
station they collapse together
you're the individual in the collective
right so
i think we just right now we're in a
place of transition
towards there so we're still pulling you
know left right you're right you're
wrong
you're wrong you're right when really
we're just too soon
right so we're projecting onto the
future so we're slowly walking towards
the place where that actually works
but right now where we are it just we're
living on both
you know our legs are in both places
right now so there is something about
that
there is um i think and again that comes
from understanding the purpose of human
beings
without human beings being the center of
creation
when you understand consciousness is the
center of creation
and the evolution of consciousness as
it's building itself a home in the
universe
we're just a vehicle towards that but as
long as you're going to keep human
beings as the center of creation
you're not going to see it you're not
gonna find it yeah you know you're still
like you said in that
um illusion the ego the blindfold
yes which which is functional
to a certain point sure yeah and then
you hit the breaking point like in the
parable of the prodigal son
you you said this earlier and it's
really important to
bring up again that
the fundamental pedagogy that
is taught to infants and toddlers and
children
is of separation
and then that is what makes it so that
the egoic bubble condom
blinders ends up
staying with a adolescent and then
an adult and then even a grandparent
until maybe the time that they die
finally they recognize that they've
merged into the ocean right at that last
moment
and so that
now in the pedagogy if you
hit at the level of the infant the
toddler if you hit at that level
the recognition that you come from the
same source the same infinitive the same
very
non-dual oneness fundamentally first and
foremost number one principle as that
number two principle is that you are a
unique expression
of that then then it makes it so that
you recognize the ocean first and you
recognize your uniqueness
as a fish in that
ocean and so i really agree with you
that it has so much to do with the
fundamental
pedagogy level and to not
you see you see many indigenous
traditions around the planet
that don't have the egoic bubble form
because upon birth it's the recognition
of oneness first
yeah i think for a lot of people just
hard to hold
that thought i'm one but i'm everyone at
the same time
it's hard to hold it right and
that's for me when water came into play
when you use water as the symbol for the
soul for that consciousness that's when
you can
have somebody visualize it materialize
it
oh i'm a cup of water when i die you
pour that cup back to the ocean
so when you pour it back to the ocean
where's the trace of
what you were before yeah yeah and more
than that can you find that water again
did you find it
right so something like really that's
where it is um
that's why i use water so much because
it just
it's it's something you can actually um
visualize contextualize
because otherwise it's just it's just
hard for most people because life
is so much invested so much in your
illusion of the individual
it puts so much work into that
i mean everything is designed for you to
be the individual but i don't know i
mean
again i think it's finding that right
balance and transitioning at the right
time
so you don't lose that motivation but
today i see people that are very
successful but they have
zero um not even one drop
of spirituality connection bigger
picture in their life
so even though they found success in
matter in everything that as human
beings would imagine as success
but they have so much depression anxiety
stress and that comes from the lack of
knowledge of
what you describe as knowledge of the
source who you are what you are right
yeah
so then once i think and i think that
comes again from that idea of like
we are right they are wrong there's only
two
totally places in this world you either
believe in size or believe in god
and i'm like wait a minute there's
something in the middle because it's not
it's not either you're this evangelical
you know believing in the seven days of
creation as
is or you believe in science like
there's something in the middle and
and all the debates we see is always
they take the most extreme
of both put them together in one room
and have a bottle and i was like oh my
god okay i'm going with science because
this is
you know so for most people they're
misguided
totally and kind of pushed away and i
think that's just
politics just it's pure politics people
fighting for
power yeah so church had the power then
science came like hey we're gonna take
the power
yeah yeah and now the science science is
the new church yeah
and and they're as destructive the
religion of materialism
was science
so and that's so i think now people are
ready to break down
totally now it's that's time yeah yeah
it's it's so
interesting yeah 500 years pendulum
swings
and now it's like hold on a second
consciousness
is fundamental hold on a second
exactly and so now it's a very
and also it's funny because in a sense
it was like religion
was the baton and then it pendulum swing
to the
to science and now it's interesting
because the pendulum swing
isn't to religion it's the spirituality
it's like a higher level it's like the
mystic
traditions of the religion yeah because
we're
we have to understand i think people
forget and live with so much judgment
if you go back to what was religion
religion was everything it was
government art
science philosophy it was the police it
was the jail it was
the courthouse it was everything and
then we created government we created a
police we have a jailhouse we have
institutions we have um science art
so now religion can be free
to be just the spiritual the mystic side
of it
yeah because it doesn't have to be
anymore the
government yes it doesn't have to do all
those things it's used to do it right
so people forget those things i mean if
you're a scientist
and you don't give credit to religion
for even making it possible for science
to come forward
yeah yeah totally so you're just it's
just pure
hate hatred and judgment you know
but so today we are actually free to
move on
to a place where we can just absorb
spirituality on its own
free from government free from you know
all the things that make it
um controlling
that's i really i really like that point
it's almost like
the mystic traditions within the
religions around the planet again
mysticism means
one becoming one with the absolute or
the ultimate or god
hinosus yoga that's what mysticism means
it's almost like those mystic traditions
in the religions they
in a sense they couldn't breathe they
were kind of choked out because religion
was also involved in all of these other
aspects to life and now that these
institutions
around government and geo economics and
around institutions for universities and
and science analyzing
form in biology and chemistry and
physics etc
it liberated the need of
religion to be so over entangled and
involved
with their tentacles and all of those
things which now makes it so that people
can
given the computers in the information
technology age
in one year you can read
the doubted qing confucius's analects
the old and new testament you can study
the sufi metaphysics you can study
gnosticism you can go to theravada
buddhism
dogchen you can take antiogens
you can jump into all of these
different understandings of mysticism
so fast and pull a big meta pattern
of what their what they were all talking
about
and unite with infinity with source
even in just a year of like full-time
work
that used to take 40 years in a
monastery
right yeah i mean we have access to that
it's kind of like we're going back to
because i think you know
just like we came from a source of
singularity of one consciousness
what we're doing in the material world
we're pushing back to that place of
singularity
where like i said we will be again a
cell in the bigger body
which is fully connected so now you are
isolated
and slowly we form you see all the
technology around us right now
which is broadcasting to other people
but slowly that will become a place
where
we are constantly connected and and in
a way that we can all hear each other
all the time
but not just here we all think together
right so we're just
recreating that's the fractal again
we're building
in a bigger scale something that already
exists in your body
your body is a hundred trillion cells
living in singularity 30 trillion we
think but yeah
yes however even if it's one trillion
right yeah because we're just
eight seven billion people right so that
trillion cells
living in singularity is you right now
and then imagine a society of a trillion
people living in singularity
so we're just scaling up constantly but
the technology already exists
in your body nothing is new we're just
scaling up
right so the individual cell of water is
now you're
that bigger scale of that yes because
water
creates and builds you know single cells
is really the
where life is totally single cells when
totally it's the fundamental building
block we're giant
but of consciousness in the material
world we're giants so we don't even see
or acknowledge that which is the beauty
of
of that singularity that you are yeah so
at
some point we'll grow to have that
singularity again where a trillion
people connected together will wake up
an even a larger body of consciousness
that will operate in the universe
and so on and so on you know yes yes
we'll keep doing that
but yeah um you've heard of hollands
yes hollands yeah and holar keys it's
like the
cell is a fundamental unit in the organ
which is a fundamental unit in the body
which is a fundamental unit in the
civilization which is a fundamental unit
in the universe
and yeah so they're all embedded within
one another like this and it's turtles
every way forever right yeah
fractal again yes that's the beauty of
it yeah and i think what's interesting
today because we were talking about how
like you know we swung into science but
now
um what is the most common topic of
conversation today
is identity it's identity yeah right so
science tells you science was like this
is who you are this body
and then people started like well
actually i don't feel like
this is who i am i'm actually more
feminine or masculine
or more this or more that like the
entire conversation now
is about identity identity yeah and
people are starting to say rebel against
their physical identity yeah because
you before you enter this body there's a
full spectrum between the
masculine and feminine that you are as a
spirit
and then there's a full spectrum of
bodies you enter to between masculine
and feminine
they don't always line up so suddenly
somebody was like wait a minute
yeah i actually feel different from the
physical reality that i was born into
which completely shatters you know the
whole idea of like there's only the
physical there's only your body
and for me it's it's joyful to watch
people
you know like they're running around
hitting walls still trying to figure out
yeah
and then i was like well i'm water yep
i don't have gender i don't have sex i
don't have any of those things those
things
anything that this body has is not who i
am yes i'm just in that body just like
you're in this house right now
that's not who you are you build it you
make it you dwell in it
but it's not who you are yeah and and
even i get pushback sometimes it's like
oh that's offensive
to the lgbtq or i'm like no
you're offensive to me your attachment
to your body
is offensive your attachment to your
body is what's causing
so many of the downstream issues as a
planet
because you need to be right about
your identity and separation and
separation
like that's all people all hold on to is
like my separation
and they and instead of advice instead
of walking away from that
we keep branding right we keep branding
it with new
it's like the onion layers and segments
onion layers are getting new names
more letters and more letters and more
races and more yes i'm like wait a
minute if you're
you know if your parents are mixed and
their parents were mixed and like
don't you see that you're losing your
identity that you were holding on to
so high and if you go up that great
chain of being your parents parents
parents parents parents parents parents
parents
what do you get to you get to the same
[ __ ] source yeah
that we all come from yeah so it's a
lose-lose game for anyone that is
chasing their identity through their
body
yeah and through the material world
you're going to lose the game eventually
but you just don't know it yet and
you're going to be miserable on the way
there
have yet to find somebody that's happy
happy yeah within that equation
of attachment identities onion layers
yeah yeah
so it's just more separation more find
people that are happy attach their onion
layers of identity
yeah if anything they just try to make
you miserable
it's like what are your onion layers of
identity it's like i am
water yeah exactly which is equal to the
water in your body which is equal to
your water yeah
but our bodies themselves will never be
equal just this
effect you know just yep the bundle of
soil that
was bundled up to make my body and the
mind it's just different
yeah you know the matter is not the same
but consciousness is
yes so we're as far as like we're
99 like you said in dna same thing in
the water in your body that's it equal
yep and water is the architect of that
dna so it also makes sense
yeah and another really good one that i
feel like you'll like that we use on the
show quite a bit
is that when you look at the eyes
you see the pupil
is like the shared observer or witness
or consciousness
and then the iris which is the unique
coloration
right that's like the unique expression
right so you have that oneness the
sameness in the pupil and then you have
the differentiation
individuation in the iris and what's the
people
it's nothing it's a void it's a void
there you go
it's not void that is shared yeah
exactly yeah that's cool
cool cool yeah i figured i really like
that one yeah you're
you got it you got it right away and and
i really like how you put it about
attachment to identity i really
i seriously think that the most upstream
issue
is that we don't recognize our true
nature
if you once you get the true nature
and you get that it's an expression of
infinity a big
play then you
kind of dissolve the ego you dissolve
you pop that condom bubble and it's not
to say that
you no longer have identity because when
somebody says hey moses will you
bring me the microphone you you won't
say
i identify only as water you know
so you still know how to navigate the
space of when people
do things like that but fundamentally
you don't have
attachment anymore to those layers
of identity and that's the big
difference and it a lot of this it
really does feel like the most upstream
solution to all of our downstream
problems is especially
curious to hear what you think about
this you've been here almost 20 years
now
in los angeles we've been here
since november of 2020 so
four months or so approaching five
one of the most important places
to pop that egoic bubble
is in the most powerful people in the
world
there's two thousand two hundred
billionaires on the planet
there's about two hundred twenty five
thousand ultra high net worth people on
the planet people that have about 30
million or so us dollars in assets
there's 535 people in the u.s congress
there's all the fortune 500
ceos there's the 200 plus u.n
general assembly how do you feel
and all of the other celebrities
influencers in los angeles and whatnot
how do you feel about
the most upstream thing being that
popping of the egoic bubble in the
people with the most leadership
in this dream well i mean i think with
their
um so again there's the function of life
and i think they are playing an
important role in the
function side of things right so let's
say
elon musk right like
whether he sees it or not he's paving
the way to what i think we
need to do from the point of view of
water is moved to space
gain independence in space independence
of movement moving all water to space
for example
so whether you wake him up or not it
wouldn't matter because he's doing what
he's supposed to do within that
equation so i think there's people that
operate blindly within
the paradigm of life
but they're still guided right there's
nobody in this life that is not doing
the right thing
it's more what do they feel about it
do they enjoy it today so again i think
there's two different layers to that
um but like i said the evolution of
creation is happening constantly and
improving constantly
but then it left for us maybe that's the
only free will we have is whether you
will enjoy it or not
when there you will find um satisfaction
inspiration motivation that's the only
thing left for us to do
because like i said you have no free
will in living you have to eat
drink have a shelter hopefully health
insurance hopefully have a comfortable
you know what i mean like
you're constantly trying to create a
life where you are
having a good life physically
the mental side of things is kind of
where the free will
is so i think
while it's important and possible to
help people
um find that you know that joy
in their life and what they do i don't
know exactly
yeah i don't know like i don't see any
one person with a target on their back
that i need to pop their
bubble i see it more as like
i'm i'm this let's say if i'm that nail
i'm going to be here in place and those
that
hit against this will pop exactly but if
i go and pop their bubble
yeah i'm an aggressor i did something
violent in a way right so there has to
be the earnest seeking any way to get
the bubble pop for it to be something
that's a permanent change
anyway yeah so it's a so that's why i
made channel water
that's why i put so i make sure that
everything that i personally
find is shareable for free
accessible all the time that's the only
goal that's right there's one thing i
can and have to do because it's like you
said the professions you know
there's people that are dentists lawyers
mechanics we're the same
in our field and this is one of all
those fields
so as as it is important for me to find
the dentist to fix my tooth
to mechanic to fix my car for the person
that wants to fix that part of their
life they'll find you
and they'll get that operated on and
fixed or
or yeah right so i think
um because it's important to not think
that what we do is in any way more
important than what everyone else is
doing
yeah because it's all the
modulating of
nothingness expressing itself
and then the ego is what says that
what i am doing is more important
although then simultaneously we hold
that
somebody that is
creating violence malevolence
is of course
in this non-dual understanding as
important as somebody that's creating
benevolence
and yet in the dualistic level it's
obviously the person that's creating
violence is
we need to bring that down and heal that
person so that they no longer create
violence
whereas the person that's creating
benevolence is like two thumbs up
question when we go to space
because i'm recognizing more and more
that the
the way that the void expresses itself
is both all the way in
and all the way out and so it's almost
as though
consciousness is going to
turn inward like in the parable of the
prodigal son and continue recognizing
its infinitude its own
voidness inward yet it's also going to
go out into space and do all of the
celestial
exploration which is awesome but
you can't this is a good question i ask
you
we're still using the same hydrological
cycle that dinosaurs drank from 66
million years ago
and so do we have to bring water
we have to bring
like a billion or a trillion gallons
of water with us to let's say the
space station that's housing a million
people that's orbiting
earth that will then
that billion or trillion gallons of
water that we brought whether it's sea
water that then becomes desalinated and
then we drink that
and then we urinate it and then we cycle
it
back we kind of create our own
hydrological cycle on the
is that what we have to to do in order
for it to be
on the space stations
yeah so your the question is asked from
the point of view of a human being not
of water
yeah correct so correct from the point
of view of water what it
what the goal is is to live this planet
right what's the worst thing that can
happen to water
another ice age okay
for water to be frozen it's to be frozen
in time you lose your freedom of
movement
you lose everything you lose your
ability to build create
our entire mechanism the reason you were
created
you're the you're the spaceship
right now you're just creating the rest
of your body to leave this planet
so we couldn't leave this planet in
dinosaurs it was too big
and that's cellular right we're the
first cell of our creatures
that's why compare us to a single cell
where the first time that a single cell
has created itself in a larger scale
now we're creating new collages of those
single cells
right so you can look at the a bus
or a hotel or a cruise ship these are
all new
collections you know like collages of
single cells
spaceship is one that's now is
self-sustainable
now the point of view of it is not from
human being it's from water
now water is flowing through that
spaceship
and happen to flow through your body but
it's water that is kept liquid
it's kept in the temperature it wants to
be it's moving
it's connected it's away from the salt
away from the cold
so once you understand water and what it
needs are what
preference are then you see that all
that life is doing is creating
architecture for that body of
consciousness which is water
so that's that's how i see it so
basically
the future of water is to be in those
channels
flowing through infinitely
in a different form that is independent
and not
open to the elements
and yet we'll also need the physical
component of it we're using the physical
well
we're using the physical matter to house
the water and also to hydrate
so that was that was basically the
question because you might you might not
be any more functioning as a human being
the way you are now
you might be completely plugged into
that
whatever structure is you see what i
mean
like oh so you might not need to drink
the water or no i'm saying you will
but you might not see it as a human
being anymore i'm drinking water
yeah you might be fully connected with
all the cells
like that's what i'm talking about the
singularity yeah yeah at that moment you
don't see yourself anymore as a single
human being
in this stepping stone though it seems
like we'll need to bring
the water with us in the stepping stone
yeah i mean
the space station right now already does
it they already bring
they have a certain amount of water and
that cycles through yes there's no new
water coming or
water going so they already have a
closed 250
gallons or something whatever yeah
something like that and it's just in a
clutch
but our goal is to basically evacuate to
the entire ocean
out of here is that really yeah that's
how i see it yeah oh that's really
interesting
we're the evacuation plants we're the
evacuation plant
the ocean is not happy it's cold it's
salty it's under the elements it's not
this is not the ideal
situation for the ocean that's why it
created plants animal people
the ocean is constantly moving out yeah
of the ocean
interesting constantly trying to leave
the salt behind an explosion
and the migration of life
from the singular to multi-cell to land
is also that water itself
can then use the water yeah
the ocean is homeless plants animal
people are the houses
yeah yeah so i mean that's what
consciousness is doing in the universe
is
creating itself a home water is
source water is infinity water is
homeless
and then it makes the cell
multi-cell plants
animals humans as homes
yeah that's interesting and then
consciousness now if you were a tree you
would know that
and you'll be fully connected with all
trees all single cells
but it's just as a human that's the only
time that you're
separated yeah is that you imagine
separation
in a short amount of time for a specific
purpose
yeah yeah
yeah this the depth of
identity as water is
super fruitful there's a lot of
nuances to it that you just kind of keep
going in its
depth and connecting it to different
frameworks and concepts that help
it be then that
infinity or source being water
takes the channel channels
the water into these
expressions of form and identity just
like all of the expressions of cells and
multi-cells and plants
animals humans and so that's why you
call
channel water because that's an infinity
or that source
channel watering through these
expressions of forms that are their
unique little fireworks
in eternity and it will probably keep
expressing itself
in a different way like yes um
just like because we're creating new
creatures in space right
that'll be new evolution is not done so
just like when you go out to the street
and you know which cars is yours even
though it was made exactly the same like
because we personalize everything even
your phone
we personalize things that's what
consciousness is
it's kind of always a person at that
moment right at that moment so
even those space stations will be
personalized as a being
right we don't know yet their shape and
you know
again consciousness will always express
itself out
so now there'll be a new function
there'll be new intention there'll be
new form
we don't know what it is yet but it
keeps happening i mean
even there's so many people now creating
spaceships and rockets and none of them
are the same
and it's like there's always expression
coming through
but i think um you know the function
the form they're connected but the
function first is to
get water into architecture yeah
that's that's the function yeah okay
interesting so as though source or
infinity or water here is the
architect in this eternal creation where
getting it into
form to reflect on its own
being in existence is
you know the the first thing that it
does in these expressions
make it get the houses so that it can
recognize itself
and then continue the personalization
and expression
of everything outward
and we'll find more water there's water
in space that is frozen
totally our job is to find it and bring
it back to the cycle
so we're not even like it's not even the
whole body of consciousness right now
that's operating
oh that's interesting i think the way to
see it is that
um when you add water to the
hydrological cycle that's
so we in a sense we're mining for water
in the cosmos
what see it more is like you have um a
part of your family that is lost
oh frozen in time and he's waiting for
you to come and save it
i mean we're the reality we're in now is
kind of like post-war
reality so imagine a time before where
there was a planet of waters
and it was content it was just this one
ocean of consciousness
all of the water in space was in one
place
and it was surrounding a sun that was
basically keeping it liquid and warm
yes there was this beautiful um kind of
like
balance between the two that kept the
water liquid out in space
something happened and that exploded and
now we're still picking up the pieces
and slowly
moving back to that place of singularity
of the entire ocean being liquid
connected
and together so again it's not about
people it's about consciousness and a
much bigger body of consciousness
so the ocean basically acts as uh
it acts as a cosmology in a sense it
acts as a philosophy it acts as a
spirituality as a metaphysics water does
water is not matter water is a
metaphysics
yeah it's the expression of metaphase
it's the if you had to
put your finger on what is the symbol
or let's say this way water is the glove
on the hand of consciousness
right so i'm not even saying water is
consciousness
it is how consciousness operates through
yeah it's like the portal for
consciousness right
because i don't want to take away from
consciousness to put it to limit it to
just being water
because that would be wrong too total
absolutely
okay so it's a portal for consciousness
it's where activity
lies right architecture of life you can
take a rock you can leave it okay
so we use water as the activity
agent yes for infinite creation yes
oh that's interesting because it has to
be
somewhere right there has to be
somewhere that
that infinite source is coming through
and operating in this world
and that place is water
that's interesting so water
interesting water is the portal yeah
that emptiness nothingness
modulating uses for
consciousness in infinite creation
in this material world right because we
created matter
doesn't matter in this water there there
is a
you see what i mean like matter is fixed
it's a building block it does not change
it's passive
and i call it passive consciousness or
potential consciousness
water is active consciousness it's the
kinetic force of consciousness
it's not just the potential so as
consciousness comes into being
it came into being in this reality in
this layer into matter and water
and water is the active part that is
moving matter and building
that's if yeah just understanding the
game the rules of the game yeah
so
usually it's
also broken down into things like
energy so even at the level of
energy which we could say is what
air and water and food are
so could you go another layer deeper
into energy
the way i phrase it is differently is
it's different it's
water uses energy to manipulate matter
so energy for me is not
consciousness is consciousness we
call it energy because we think energy
is something
abstract but energy is energy
it's actually very physical it's physics
so there's
all the different kinds of energy which
we're using right we're heating
we need energy to heat the water right
so
water itself depends on how much energy
it has
will determine how active it is so like
we said
ice is frozen in time yeah there's no
time there's no activity
then the warmer it gets the more active
it gets
the more force it has the more energy it
has right so
energy is just um
so yeah i mean the best way is in a
sentence water uses energy to manipulate
matter
or consciousness uses energy to
manipulate
matter and that one
yeah i see i'm not the energy yeah i'm
conscious consciousness is
always energy
is something else you know you can drain
an energy from a battery
and you can drain life life is not
something that
it's it's not an on off switch it's
eternal
it's exactly it's consciousness
because it seems like what's most
foundational
is the energy that is dancing
that then from emptiness to energy
dancing that then creates the
appearances
of
matter form
even the houses
that then
have the ability to reflect on
their source so
if if it was put into a trajectory it
would be something like
although i am
consciousness i am eternal
life that is what i am
that even the beyond of that
is something like the absolute
the void shunya emptiness etc
that then uses awareness
or the agent of
consciousness to experience
all of these different fluctuations of
energy modulations it does
i see how that whole process can be
viewed like
water it can be viewed like a sine wave
it can be viewed like
the modulation of the waves on the ocean
i see how all these things are
intertwined and interrelated
so water in a sense is like the analogy
that is used
to reference the modulation
of the oceanic-ness in all of its
possibility
and then these appearances of form are
like those
most surface level waves that appear
and then disappear and appear and
disappear in different form possibility
right but it's again it's
water i mean think about being water not
being a person like being water
like fully connected
so that moment you're not a tree
or a grass or you know you fully
you don't even have that identity or the
idea of the thing
there's no thing yes so that's kind of
like when you
when you die when you dissolve from the
body and you go back to that
it's like this that space yeah the space
it's that space of it right yeah
but at the same time it's not matter
you know it's like um because you
because if you have to take matter and
make something
you have to be able to move around and
do it it's it's like the wa
the voidness or the nothingness the
water is more likely but it's posed the
void
right it's post-avoid that's what i was
sort of also trying to
that's why i was also trying to put it
at the level of energy
but i see how it's all like the
spaceness is more
also it's just from our point of view as
people when we look at the spirit it
looks like water
but when you are water you're not water
yeah
you know it's just our point of view
through these eyes that's what it looks
like
yeah but when you're the thing itself
itself
yeah there's nothing so this can be
thought of as
when you think of yourself as the
appearance of the wave
and then you think of these objects as
also appearances
of the wave
and then you recognize that
the oceanic feeling of where
you are water and these are water
and the space is water and that's all
water
that recognition versus thinking that
i'm a wave i'm a form right it's more
like the particle on the wave
right yeah yep yeah it could be a
thinking i'm a particle but actually
when you look at it you see that that
particle
is inside of a wave so
it's almost like being able to modulate
yourself
quantum mechanically in the probability
space
to oceanic feeling and then as needed
hey moses will you pass me that mic
okay particle pass like you know
whatever
you tell the story all these different
ways right it's okay because i'll be
like well we're
the same being you go do it yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly
okay i definitely that was such a great
metaphysical
exploration i love that i wanted to make
sure that we
asked you as much as you were willing to
share
about the process
of which one can even photograph
water like this this started in 2013
is that right okay so yeah walk us
through
um how does one
even get to the point where they
discover
that they can photograph water this way
and as much of
what you're feeling is free to share
we would love to learn about the method
itself too yeah
so i think one thing we have to
understand first is that
we do not see water like light
passes through water okay so yeah so
let's let's let's just bring
the example here so okay so what
what what are we seeing here
so what you see here is basically the
way
the shape of the glass and those
structures break light
right if you had a perfectly square
glass clear clean water
you will see through it as if it wasn't
there right so a good example
if you have an aquarium what do you look
at
the fish what's between you and the fish
nothing you see the fish right if mean
you're now in water i see you
right so i don't see water we don't see
the air too
right we don't see the area the only
thing that we see is the border between
the two
okay so when i look at this water i'm
seeing you're telling me that i'm seeing
the cup holding the water
you see reflections right reflections
heating the cup hitting the water
the the light goes through but gets
deflected
yeah right so you've seen all those you
see prisms you see
all kind of things that are happening to
the light as it's moving through the
water
so the only thing you can tell me is
that i know there's water there yeah i
know there's water
there that's the only thing that you
actually know right yeah but you don't
see
now to see water is to see the movement
within the water
right so that's why we using air is a
good example
you don't see the wind yes but if
there's particles in the wind you'll see
it
yes a twister a hurricane a shape right
yes
so same with water so the leaf moving
through the
wind is like the fish in the aquarium
yes or for example if you're in a lake
or an ocean there's lots of debris
bacteria right so you see that but you
don't see the water
okay so even a block of ice
of perfect clear water in a perfect
square shape
you will see through it as if it wasn't
there so just question of do you have
air bubbles
particles so okay so now what we do want
to see
is we want to see movement in the water
you want to see the actual
form of water just like you see the wind
okay i want to see
so so you're saying i want to see
this water i want to see the water
itself
photographed to where i can see its
form at that level when those images are
not microscopic that's exactly
this this size so
what happened yeah if we took this photo
it would just look like a block of
ice like a block of blue ice like that
it will look like different forms of
it you will see the movement i will see
movement as long as i do this
but if it's been sitting still for five
minutes
then it will be solid right ish well
water never stops moving
so yeah even those little molecules will
keep
it's always moving h2o will keep moving
so what will what will we see it will we
will feel
you'll see as you go through the images
that's exactly what you will see
so you will see this water didn't you
move it
in a certain way to capture it like this
right so
what you what you want to see
is the movement in water right that's
that's what we want to see
so in order to see that you can't use
light
you can't no light goes through the
water so you're not going to get
anything
with light and what you want to do
is to be able to capture that movement
how do you capture
three dimension in the water so this is
more of a kinetic photography where the
film
itself is liquid and and
it's it's sensitive to movement so what
i'm capturing is the movement
in the water right that's what i'm
capturing here so once there's
movement film is liquid it's liquid but
it doesn't mix with the water
they don't mix what so
for example liquid yeah now if you go
on my playlist faces of water there's
different kinds so there's water from
different places but also
the most exciting thing is sound waves
in water
because cymatics right yeah yeah because
all
mythologies describe life as a
vibration the beginning of life being a
certain vibration
which means a frequency because we think
about sound is communication yes but
sound is actually like a 3d printer in
water
sound is like a 3d printer in water it's
a way to create three-dimensional forms
okay so water uses sound to create forms
and when you see the forms of um
sound waves in water you see the
architecture of life you see
the patterns of trees you see the world
of biology coming
to life yes so for me the most exciting
one to do is
i create those big speakers of water and
back in 2013 before cinematics was so
popular yeah
and and capturing those movements the
sound moving through the water
okay and that's that's the most
incredible thing you'll ever see
because so that's like the fundamental
[Music]
frequencies yeah and then tweaking those
frequencies to have different shapes
fractal appear
yeah and just like humans trees animals
plants
everything starts appearing up here yeah
and then the side of that i mean you
have also just pure movements of water
and water
so yes but you see why i said energy
seemed like it was so
fundamental right because like all those
different modulations energetically
are what give rise to the different
appearances of
form right but again consciousness is
the one yeah yeah
using energy yes or being energized just
yeah right yeah it just i think it's
just a matter of
how we use language yes yes because a
lot of times people will use the word
awareness to describe consciousness
they'll use the word energy to describe
you know what i mean
yeah so for me it's like consciousness
is the thing itself
yeah consciousness is aware of its
surrounding that's how i use the word
awareness
okay most people use it the other way
yeah most people say
awareness is the primary agent of
infinity
and then consciousness is sort of the
agent of what matter
sort of becomes
to recognize itself as awareness so
consciousness recognizes itself as
awareness but awareness is the
fundamental agent
anyway right no but it's important
because at that moment
they're talking about the brain when
yeah consciousness is usually in
reference to the brain whereas awareness
is like the witness or the observer
right yeah but that's where we lose a
lot of people because they start
thinking consciousness only exists if
you have a brain
if you have a brain yeah but so it's
consciousness but if there's nothing
around
there's no awareness there's nothing to
be aware of so you could be
consciousness and have nothing to be
aware of
so awareness is an action consciousness
takes
okay interesting okay i see i see how
you
but your whole body is conscious not
just the brain
and your whole body is then the word to
different things in different places
yeah but
okay yeah okay so same thing with energy
that's why i say consciousness uses
energy to manipulate matter okay yeah
all those words okay i put them in
sentences so just so you know what i
mean at least
you know then you can translate it to
the way you use it yeah yeah
oh that's so funny it's almost like uh
translating
spanish you know it's kind of funny like
that
so yeah so how would you do so you use
did you make this um film
that you made it you made the film that
could yeah
and anyone can it's not something so
that's why the patent is more of a
the method okay uh it's an actual method
so people
sell this film that's the film itself is
just a
chemicals you can buy the chemicals and
put it together like it's not
that part again it's not um but you
can't use light
no light involved whatsoever you can do
it in pure darkness okay so
but did you do these pictures in pure
darkness
yeah there's no light involved okay so
walk us through
how you're in pure darkness oh so so for
example
what you see in the image yes the range
of color right so the most
bright one is the most like is we said
energy in the water right yeah and black
is no movement so
maximum movement to normal okay yeah so
that's what you've seen in the images
let's move to another image that maybe a
bigger um
so here for example you can see the
movement
and the flow so
so what so that movement in the water
that specific movement what you see
but you're in a dark room i mean i'm i
could be
anywhere all i'm saying is that the film
itself is not affected by
light it's affected by movement although
the film's affected by movement
now i see okay so the um
so basically once you so you might you
might
in the dark room you might move the
water
put the film in it'll capture that
movement
take it out something like that right
and then at the end i have a negative
you have a negative yeah okay now i got
it okay so the film i can choose when to
fixate the film
right so i'm like that's like me taking
a snapshot yes
so okay i can let's say i create sounds
in the water
okay i drop my film into the water and
when i choose
i fixate the film i capture that second
how do you
choose that's something that's probably
that's proprietary yeah that's
proprietary okay
okay so yeah but it's also it's an
analog process
so at the end i have negatives yes
actual physical negatives
yes and this is the positive yeah
totally okay okay cool okay
but what you can see like here for
example that's basically the
blueprint of a fish yeah yeah
and then you start to see that movement
in water is the
the architecture the appearance of form
the architecting
and why things look the way they look
why things look like
so what how did you replicate
this movement this isn't cymatics
no this one was just a pure and and
funny enough somebody made a project
where they dropped
um liquid wax in
the top of a river they just dropped wax
into the river
and the wax formed itself as it went
down the river and at the end when they
captured it they looked like
fish you know it's the same thing here
yeah yeah
so same thing here it's the same thing
there's that type of movement
and this one that's what came out oh my
gosh so in a sense
so is water moving inside of water yeah
yeah that's what we're seeing is the
movement of water in water
the movement of water in water that's a
great way to put it so
so would it be fair then to say
something like uh
like
the way that we see imagine earth as a
fractal
and you see the
the way that the mountains secrete out
of
the land and then you see how the
hydrological cycle from the ocean
moves and
precipitates a snowfall and then
goes the streams from there become the
rivers that then go back to the ocean
right the hydrological cycle
so fish are the formation
in a sense the way they're positioned
like their head
with their body and their little tails
of water
of the movement of water in water
so the very hydrological cycle is in a
sense what creates the appearance
of the way that why these fish are
shaped the way they are
is that yeah yeah you start to see how
just like we create you know things to
be aerodynamic
yeah this is liquid dynamics yeah so
this is the liquid dynamics
liquid fluid dynamics it's called yeah
fluid dynamics
so you have you create the most
ideal shape and form to move in water
and you can see that i mean when you
look at a shark and the way and the
ability they have
is amazing totally
even a whale i mean i saw whales swim in
the ocean until you see it
in person next to them it's you don't
really grasp
how amazing and effective it is you see
a building swimming next to you
that's it you're like wow this thing i
mean the movement it's much more like a
snake the way this like
they move rather than we keep thinking
this chunk of
no they have a very fluid movement and
it's amazing especially that scale
so all of life started as water moving
in water
yeah then taking form right and this is
part of why we don't see water is
because we're designed to see everything
but the water because we're in it
we're inside we're in it even now i mean
i don't see
like you describe the hydrological cycle
i don't even see that the oh the
atmosphere is
an extension of the ocean the atmosphere
is that it's the ocean correct it's
one body of water yeah it's just the way
the ocean protects itself from the cold
of space
is that gradient of the atmosphere yeah
yeah because again the ocean is all it's
doing is trying not to freeze
yeah constantly keeping itself
trying not to the enemy is the next size
h that's alright
i wrote that down i thought that was
interesting that the
it's better to warm up the worst age
yeah yeah cooling down is the worst
thing is the worst
yeah because you never want to be frozen
in place
well you're frozen in time in time time
time and temperature is
the same measurement yeah
from the point of view of water like for
us we have clocks so we think
time is fixed but time is actually
flexible to temperature
so the warmer it is the faster time
moves
so it can slow down to zero or it can
move to a place where it's not
functional anymore you just vapor
which is too much energy but yeah
you see it kind of in your everyday life
like if you have
if you eat food and you want to have
some left for later
and you want to slow down time you want
to slow down the process of water
in your food is it decomposing so you
put in the fridge
you slow down time yeah or you want to
completely stop it
you put in the freezer freezer so that's
time which still doesn't technically
stop it
in the sense of like you can't eat it in
a year because it'd be different there's
no absolute zero
yeah yeah yeah oh that's interesting
yeah that's interesting but it's like as
close as it gets as close as it gets
yeah which is even more torturous
because you're moving so slow
yeah oh interesting i think i'm i think
i'm following now so in a sense
and it kind of follows the whole
pressure cooker analogy too
where suffering is kind of like the
drill sergeant of awakening
so when you're faced with significant
trauma
it kind of makes you awaken
to the treasure that comes from that and
in a sense that's kind of like the
pressure cooker where
there's a
there's something that needs to happen
like we talked about this before we went
on like
israel in many ways is kind of like a
pressure cooker
for needing to use the mind
mathematically cryptographically
computer scientifically
etc to ensure its own safety
type thing
and so that's like kind of like it's not
ice it's vapor
in this sense it's like steam yeah you
get to the essence of things faster
like you have a tomato but you say like
i want the essence of the tomato but i
don't want to wait for it to
rot and ferment and so i'm going to cook
it i'm going to push it there
right so that's the movement forward or
you slow down
but you can't move back so if you want
to talk about time traveling
it's only movement forward you can't go
back interesting
so okay so again
uh you're in darkness you
no i don't have to be in darkness you
don't i'm just saying light does not
have any effect on your light
so i can be in light and i can take
the little um
film and
dip and pull out and then
process that because again that's what's
so amazing when you stop to realize that
light passes through water water ignores
light
that's that's just scientifically water
ignores light
water is so dense more than the wall
behind you
but yet light can pass through it water
is denser than
like steel just drywall behind you the
piece of wood over there
yeah so you can see that weight density
all of it
yet light passes through it how is that
even possible
okay so it's denser molecularly
h2o is packed together more so than even
wood or steel
but definitely wood definitely would
okay so
when you think about it that dance of
life that we're in
is between water and light
sure sure but they don't mix yeah so
water creates
because everything you see you see with
light but water is creating those
structures and buildings and and water
can change the wavelength of matter
to give you different colors right
because i mean the plant right now can
be green with a purple leaf totally
totally but when the water leaves that
plant
it all goes back to being just this this
color of the soil
but no nobody stopped to think for a
minute wait a minute
how does this matter how is this green
right now yeah so water has the ability
to take matter and change the wavelength
of it
to give you any color you want yeah just
like you paint your house
yeah but the reality behind that paint
or when all of that crumbles back down
to the
origin matter it's just soil we all i
mean there's nothing
else here but rock and water
jeez
it's not my preferred example but a good
example for it you can have the most
lavish dinner
with the most colorful textures
everything
on the table but the next day only two
things left your body
water and soil yeah
but water has the ability to take that
soil and create so many wonderful things
out of it
damn the cyclicity is so
the oroboros right the that
symbol of the snake eating its tail it's
everywhere
wow so that's why that space station
question
yeah that's doesn't matter you know what
i mean like it's the same cycle it just
happens in a smaller more self-sustained
containers yes that space
yeah that was the question and that and
that makes uh
that makes sense it's just crazy that
there had to be 250 or whatever gallons
brought up in the first place
for it to then undergo the cycle in the
station itself
like that's another interesting thing is
that yeah
cosmically speaking it was really
interesting when you said that
like it's almost as though it's our
responsibility to not only
spread life these little portals
for the next infants that come
throughout the cosmos but also that
it's in a sense a responsibility to go
and
save the
frozen water
from being
timeless helpless yeah
we bring time to space we bring time to
ice to space yeah
ah this is so interesting
that goes on this one so many notes
i like that we kind of
so is it
so metaphysically speaking it's
something like
the secretion
the dance
that then
has this emerge
that looks and recognizes itself and
then it takes
the essence of the creativity of what it
is
and it brings it to more and more
expression that enables it to have more
and more
expression of creativity and form
outward more and more
like like more architecture
more architecture yeah which is growth
which is growth creativity that's all
nature does is grow
and i mean growth for nature means
putting water in
houses in architecture
and then
and then so
and then the example you were giving
also
earlier was that the
autonomous car
is
a vessel
from earlier you're giving the example
the thomas cars like the
vehicle so when you say the
channeling water we are the channeling
of the water what's the autonomous
vehicle
in the analogy i mean as long as it's
just
matter it's just a rock but every vessel
of consciousness is about
every vessel of water is a vessel of
consciousness so you're the conscious
being
in the car so when something moves
in philosophy when something moves
there's two options
either your conscious being choosing to
move from point a to point b
or a conscious b and put it into
movement
right so the autumn so that car is put
into movement by consciousness
by water yeah it serves us
okay but okay a lot of people think that
consciousness
the brain hence a computer one day will
be conscious
which is not the case unless there's
water in that mix
that computer will not be conscious ever
so it can be very easy so if it's fluid
dynamics it can be
yeah if you integrate water into the
system and water is what but then again
all you're going to end up doing is
recreating yourself because that's what
is happening right now
right so where that consciousness that
is creating making all that
you know so when i sit on my computer
and i click there's no separation
between the spark
through my body i'm just waterproof so i
won't get electrified but that click
that spark goes on
through the computer to the internet to
yes whatever and something gets shipped
to my door
you know or being made and so at some
point we'll
even even that won't happen we will be
completely able to
just use waves whether it's like brain
waves or a different type of
communication
so we won't even have to use the
physical part of my body
so it'd be just water controlling matter
without
having to be mixed with it because the
mix between water and matter is that
union that cause pain and suffering
that's why i said that at some point
water will be free from that union
to flow and everything around it will be
controlled by water without
having to actually do the work having
that physical connection
that's where the friction is that's
where the pain is so that's where the
suffering is
so all of that friction pain suffering
comes from the union of water with
matter
or you can say the spirit or spirit and
matter yeah or consciousness and matter
blah blah blah
shiva shakti purusha prakriti blah blah
blah
so the component of the dance the
components of the dance so
there's a liberation of consciousness or
of water
yeah from its matter
that then enables it to do
the why the complete telepathic
yeah telekinetic yeah
oh interesting
and so that's enabled by also neuralink
etc all these types of future
brain computer interface style
technologies
probably i mean i think the way we see
it is that we
create a lot of different ways and the
best ones yeah yeah always
so that's the evolution of creation
natural selection blah blah blah
did we did we share
i guess another minor question here is
that
did you did you do some sort of uh
like a you you made a movement in the
water
and then captured it that's how you made
these
right so my goal is to find movement
right so whether i go to a stream
okay i go to the ocean i create
movements at home
and like i said the most effective
movements i found the most informatives
are sound waves in water
so then i create sound waves in the
water capture those
so we're in was this sound waves a lot
of this was sound waves
some these are actually the first images
this is before i even entered sound
um some of those had more of intention
so like the one you see on the right
yeah um
that was actually
on passover and i was
thinking about splitting the water like
i was thinking about that concept
and if you see in this image you have
this one sphere
that actually has this split in it
almost like two
faces looking at each other yet it's one
of a whole so it has this kind of
infinite flow yet it has that split
and it's kind of looking at itself yeah
yeah so
so a lot of the images at the beginning
was really just my
trying to put my i um
headspace and see what happens right
um it was kind of like imoto's work
where you know how does your feelings
affect the water
but then but then i wanted to move away
from that and focus really on things
that i can scientifically show
and that was more the sound waves in
water and things of that nature because
i didn't want to end up in a world where
i'm
constantly battling you know what i
think i see
to what other people will see where when
it sound waves it's rep
you can repeat it you can yeah you know
it's real science it's expensive like
you can actually see
this frequency will be always the same
so
so i try to always focus on things that
are more
scientific or or for example fluid
dynamics if you
zoom into the one on the right so you
will always you learn a lot about also
space space
there's always a black hole in the
center of an impact
which is also what we see in space
there's always a black hole so for
example what i learned is that the black
hole is not
where things get sucked out of life it's
actually the opposite it's the injection
point
yeah you know so this universe
is actually more like something that was
inject it's fluid dynamics and it was
injected in that's the black hole so
that's a
spark of creativity and then that thing
is flowing on
yeah yeah in that so so it's almost like
when you take the
water and then there's a the injection
point is kind of like the big bang
the point of creation yeah
so and that's just so the intention at
the level of consciousness
happens at the big bang
it's all in one right it's a fracture of
a second that yeah
and then that intention of exploration
of creativity materializes itself and
then reflects on holy [ __ ] we're here to
do
this creative explorative process that
we set out to do
13.8 billion years ago maybe
maybe maybe or maybe every second is
just
now and it's just now now
yeah i mean because time doesn't really
exist in that way like i said time
time is a measurement of energy within
consciousness with thin yeah yeah how
fast or slow you're moving
yeah but there's no cl there's no
universal clock
none so for example there's no time on
the moon and there's no
time in infinity there's no time in
eternity those are mutually exclusive
yeah time is when you you have to have a
conscious being measure its own movement
yeah for it to even be time time and
then
how fast the time goes depends on the
temperature at that place
yeah okay okay
wow and by the way what's the future for
you
with um
the faces of water as the photography
where where are you thinking of taking
the photography of
water um repeatability was one thing you
mentioned a bit
right and i've already achieved that
part for me it's more
i'm constantly just um i'm enjoying the
process
and the process of investigation so i
haven't yet stopped
you know i mean like to stop and just
focus on
one thing one thing only so i compared
this photography to like when i told you
you can invent let's say x-ray
now you study the body you can study
bones and things that you couldn't do
before
so that's what happened to me i invented
that my focus was to see the water
okay learn from it i've learned a lot
from being able to see water
and then took that knowledge and start
lecturing about what i understood from
it
yes and that touches on all aspects of
society
and life and everything we know uh one
of the latest things
the last hour and a half of conversation
right pretty much comes from
seeing movements in water that's really
cool and then one of the last things
i created was the family fluid dynamics
which explains
basically and again nothing i talk about
is new it's just from the point of view
of water
but people talked about it as
generational trauma generational curse
but it's basically you're born into a
river that was shaped by generations and
generations
so the family fluid dynamics helps you
to see the river you're born into
oh okay and basically get out of that
because you're not that river
yeah you're the water but most people
identify with the river they're born
into
it's more than matter the river banks
and the shape of it yes
because maybe you know generations ago
somebody hit an obstacle
so i'll give the metaphor quickly you're
born
your moment of birth is when the rain
hits the ground
your life cycle as a person is the
journey from that moment back to the
ocean
yes right so as the water you know
makes its way to the ocean let's say it
hits an obstacle
so now it has to go around it and it's
not anymore the ideal
path it has to start moving around and
changing its path
but then over time water you know that
obstacle
it gets dissolved eroded by the water
but the river still moves as if the
obstacle is there
you're born into that river generations
after
and you still wiggle around as if the
obstacle is there yeah yeah so like in
the
jewish world people born after you know
generations of the holocaust
still have issues with food yeah you
know so but it's not their issue
it was given to them generation after
generation so once you identify with the
water rather than the river banks
you start to see what's yours and so
it's not yours right
so that's the family fluid dynamics on
you know
quickly and then the next thing
i've been working on a project for over
a year now it's a new book and that book
is all illustrations actually
and it's a story that explains how and
why
water and nature created human beings
yes
it's called the liquid forest cool and
it's kind of a secret project we're
almost done we have two more
illustrations before it's
that part is finished and then i'm going
to start telling that story and
it's kind of like the prequel to the
bible
sweet yeah yeah that's great
yeah that that's i love that that's
actually uh
something that we're really passionate
about that we'll probably talk about
after the show
is creating art and illustrations that
then
explain source or infinity doing this
creative process
yeah why we're doing it exactly this
type of thing
i'm excited for it and also to be able
to
potentially bring you back on to be able
to explain it and have more of the
dialogue about
it so that one is
forest the liquid forest liquid liquid
forest
i like that it's cool the liquid forest
family fluid dynamics there was one part
to that that i wanted to mention
was that have you've probably heard like
in the
like in some of the non-dual
tradition it's like there there's no
such thing as enlightenment or awakening
you're already
it right right you're already water
right yeah that's not any question yeah
and so
like like even the whole like condom
bubble idea
is like we make that idea up
but we make it up in the sense like if
you think that you're separate that's
what it is
if you think that if you're experiencing
anger and frustration and jealousy and
malevolence and all these things
the way out of that is through the
buddha through the techniques that have
been passed down for
the millennia around becoming conscious
of your respiration
you know having high levels of morality
concentration
samadhi meditative consciousness that
then gives you
liberation into being water to
recognizing that you're water
like rumi said the diamond is already
around your neck but it's
up to you to recognize it
and so that's kind of the popping in a
sense so it's kind of funny that's
what it was reminding me of a little bit
so as soon as the precipitation hits
is when the birth portal in happens and
you recognize
as soon as possible i'm water i'm water
on this
journey this experience and not
you know i am like where is the border
there's no border for the little droplet
of water to be like this is where my
border well you know that's the thing is
that
you're usually you'll discover that
moment where you're inside of the river
you know what i mean like and the
question is at what moment you realize
that you're not the river
yeah that's the main thing yeah but
there's no
we talked again about the union between
the spirit and matter
so in this case the water and matter so
when the drop of water hits the ground
that's the moment of union right so now
we're already mixing with matter
and flowing through and the river can be
even
books and libraries and you know the
river banks are made of
culture you know society
all of that is the river right okay so
what would it be would it be fair to say
that you could say that
the the drop is like
if you're associated with the drop in
the identity then that's kind of like
the ego
and then the river is the journey
for the drop and then if you recognize
that you're the water
that's sort of the ultimate realization
is i'm not the drop i'm not even the
drop
in the river i'm not even the drop on
the journey i'm just
water period infinite water infinite
creation
that's what i am which is what the
mystic traditions say is that you
are source expressing itself forever
in all of the different yeah and so we
because the river i think
when i talk about the river i don't talk
about the water in the river
i'm talking about the actual physical
matter
that we call you see what i mean because
we
create separation between this water and
that water
is because it's inside of this matter in
this journey i see
so like the person the person that you
want to approach and remind them
your source your water right the person
you're talking to is that combination of
matter and water
they are that river oh they have a shape
a form
and that's they have a story they live
inside of that's exact and that's why
that's why another one of the ultimate
realizations of the mystic traditions is
that
there's no lack there's nothing good or
bad
it's literally just identity it's what
are you
identity are you the mix of the water
with the matter
or are you just the water yeah and then
and then it gives you the power to
escape that river yeah because otherwise
you're just going to repeat
the generations you know everyone
becomes their parents whether they want
to or not
yeah that's what the river does have
have you heard of stream
entry in the tradition buddhism has a
has a called sotapanya it's the stream
entry
basically it's so funny how how much
synergy there is here with the water
where stream entry is almost in a sense
when you
recognize that you're not the appearance
of the cloud
of the thought or emotion but rather
you're the sky
in which the cloud happens right right
and so
in a sense it's like you recognize that
you're not just the drop of water
but you are water in general and so
stream entry is kind of like
the beginning of nirvana the beginning
stages of recognizing there is something
to do there's something for me to
realize that i am
already water and so that's stream entry
whereas
otherwise you're just sometimes not even
recognizing that you are the ultimate
you are the absolute
having this experience yeah it's so
interesting
that's why there's many past one end and
that's why there's all this
different yeah right that's why i try to
keep it simple
yeah super child like so the book liquid
force is also going to be
is it kind of like more child visuals
same here with all the stuff we've been
doing since november it's been very
childlike visuals i'll show you some of
them down here
um afterward okay let's um
yeah let's wrap so
oh and then the channel so so besides um
the illustrations
like uh liquid forest it's also
continuing to build out the youtube
channel
that's yeah i have creating content on
there lectures coming up
i just moved so i'm in the process of
moving to a new location moving
everything but
um i'm constantly i have lots of
lectures lined up already
um the next one is going to be about
whether or not we're living a simulation
explaining why we do
and why we don't you know again
everything is from the point of view of
water
yeah so um so there's lots to talk about
because it's basically kind of an
infinite subject totally
and um and once i'm done with the
lectures and putting out the information
i have then i can just
rest okay so so the couple things is
that the
the liquid forest the continuation of
the channel
and that's kind of those are kind of
like the big things
yeah and then i will continue making
images of water because i just i enjoy
that
i actually really like them on your
i really like this oh yeah i saw this
the
it's the integratron in joshua tree in
joshua tree so i wrapped it with one
image
and it's it was 166 feet long
the image i love that this is this was
kind of what i was thinking when
when i was wondering like where can we
put
faces of water well we can put it on
all of the ugly not i mean it's our
creation
but there's so many ugly just plain
building walls that have no beauty
on them and so if we put faces of water
on you know right even right here in
koreatown
you can put it right on all of these
beautiful
building like on the sides where there's
not even any windows right
put one of those massive anyway this is
what i was thinking also about art which
is something we could potentially talk
about is just the proliferation of faces
of water
the beauty of the method is that because
my negatives are really large
and the film i'm using is made out of
nanoparticles
i can enlarge my images to any scale in
any size
and there's never ever a pixel when
people see my prints they don't
understand what they're looking at
because there's no pixels no pixels you
don't because
it's so fine and so i can take an image
of an inch by two inches and blow it up
to the empire state building and
there'll be no pixels
that is so so cool as far as buildings
yeah that's the ultimate place for
that's why i always do large scale
prints i go as big as i can
have you been have you been asked yet to
put it on a
side of a building uh yeah there was one
project that was kind of like
you know a concept they suggested but i
didn't go really anywhere
i would love to help make that happen as
soon as possible there's actually a
decent amount of artists that are
starting to
in a sense create their murals on the
sides of buildings
like on the big large scales but to be
able to take and
so the nice thing is that you'd have to
print
them that's fine that's easy to tile but
i print them on aluminum and the
aluminum we use to print is a building
material
when you see buildings that are like
silver or gray yeah it looks like metal
that's the same panels we print on so
let's say a building that's cladded with
that
could be printed very easily or it could
be printed on like vinyls
my idea was that taking you know
buildings in construct
construction they covered the
construction with this
fabric so my idea was to have those
images there
oh that's cool so while it's in
construction you get this huge
you know kind of exhibit space basically
yeah
oh and and you also have a gallery
in ingleside in englewood yeah
inglewood right inglewood inglewood yeah
that's the water museum
the water museum yeah because of kovid
we
you know couldn't open to the public but
it's supposed to be the place where
we explain everything from the science
of water
um ecology climate to philosophy
theology
i love this this is a mythology you know
like
basically everything because water is
really the one line that ties everything
together yeah
you know um so you'll put some of the
liquid force stuff potentially up as
well some of the
the drawings we're making are pretty big
so what i think i'll do is
convert the whole space to an exhibit
space for the book
so you can see all the illustrations
yeah exactly and create
installations that you actually walk
into those spaces i love that i love the
installation
yeah because that's the experiential
component of it
like uh to create sort of the
the pulsating visualization of what it's
like to
touch and then to watch like in a 3d
aquarium
for it to watch the face of water change
would be yeah that kind of stuff's so
cool um
yeah i think that's i think that's
pretty much it did you have other things
that did you have other things you
wanted to
also mention no that's pretty much it
i'll be happy to come back in the future
and
yeah we'd love to discuss more yeah
there's always more to heck yeah
and to collab on we'll explore that
stuff um
here in a bit uh
silly question let's go with
favorite food
well i am from the middle east but my
mom's food of course
what is it what's his favorite oh
there's a dish she makes with
okra we call it bamiya bamiya so it's
like
okra and this red sauce potatoes chicken
yeah rice on the side oh that's my
favorite dish in the world sounds
so good you know we're site specific
everyone likes their
yeah that's where we were born it's
metaphysical the question what's your
favorite food is metaphysical it's
really interesting
it's like if you can tell that you have
a specific taste that nobody else in the
world
kind of has that specific taste just
like your iris is a specific that nobody
else has etc
so orca with this like red with uh
chicken and potato and
yeah i guess it's kind of a tomato sauce
yeah and um
yeah an orca this kind of like okay or
okra okay yeah okra it's kind of like a
is it like kind of a green it's like a
quinoa oh no it looks
it looks like a tiny um zucchini or
um yeah i don't know what even family it
is it reminds me of a small
eggplant zucchini it's like a small
vegetable
but you have to know how to cook it
perfectly to have it
okay this is what actually sometimes i
find um like
i like southern um
this stuff food yeah so sometimes i find
like fried okra here that
um it's kind of on the american so fried
or
baked okra that's what you'll find here
mostly
interesting yeah it's still it's totally
not a it's not a grain it's a plant
yeah yeah it's not a grain well yeah
that's that's interesting okay so this
with
chicken potato rice tomato sauce
yeah here you can see the more um yeah
like what's the dish called
bamya
my mom is originally from turkey and her
family
yeah that's it oh that looks so good
yeah exactly the way it sits over there
and then with rice
yeah it looks super good yeah this is
definitely one of my favorite silly
questions to ask
and it's so metaphysical too which is
super interesting
um okay cool let's uh let's wrap so
so uh yeah everyone uh check out the
links in the bio below
uh thanks for tuning in we love you very
much we're really grateful a super fun
conversation with moses
you can find all of his links in the bio
below
go and subscribe to his youtube channel
and check out those videos really nice
and informative content there
also uh follow him on instagram you can
find his book
link in the bio below as well to the
faces of waterbook
and then also his website
faceswatter.com all those links are in
the bio below
comment below with what you think about
the episode we'd love to hear from you
about identifying as water we would love
to hear how you feel about that
like the video share it with other
people subscribe if you haven't
let's catalyze more of that oceanic
feeling
that was uh that's a wrap i think that's
it moses any other thoughts on the way
out
no no i'm hungry yeah yeah okay let's
wrap thanks everybody for tuning in we
love you very much i know the bomb yeah
okay we love you very much we will see
you soon thanks everyone peace